it's time to play the blame game and it
might not be what anybody in our
audience wants to hear every time
there's an election the losers start the
blame game after the fact with
yesterday's win by Donald Trump
it's the racist vote it's James Comey in
the FBI it's Jill Stein and Gary Johnson
it's uh who knows what it is my plan
today is to talk about the path forward
and if we are blaming the wrong things
for the destructive and despicable win
of Donald Trump as president of the
United States we're not going to fix the
problem if you can identify the cause
you cannot possibly fix the problem now
I hate racists as much as as much as Pat
does
I think Rachel hates races she's ever
said it but I assume she hates races too
as much as many in our audience do but
blaming racists for Trump winning is
just wrong and it will get us absolutely
nowhere racism exists it's been
catalyzed by President Obama being the
first half black president of the US but
racists are not why Hillary Clinton lost
James commies back and forth on
investigating Hillary Clinton didn't
help Hillary Clinton it's true that
without that some of these states with
small margins Wisconsin for example
might have gone Hillary's Way
Pennsylvania might have gone Hillary's
way but the fact that she wasn't so far
ahead of the most fundamentally
unqualified presidential candidate in
who knows how long tells us we can't
just blame James Comey his actions and
those of the FBI are horrible and
deplorable but what action can you take
by blaming James Comey for the results
here and this one is really angering me
guys there are Democratic voters or just
Hillary voters who might be independent
a Republican blaming Jill Stein and Gary
Johnson for this loss if you think that
you were living in a fantasy world and
I'm seeing this even on corporate media
and and the the Talking Heads talking
about it if anything the third party
candidates helped Hillary Clinton not
loses badly there is nothing to the idea
that Hillary Clinton was hurt by Gary
Johnson or Jill Stein in any electoral
way let's go to the map and I'll just
give you a couple of examples here if we
look at Florida Donald Trump won by one
point three points in Florida Gary
Johnson had 2.2 percent support and most
of that support was taken from Donald
Trump
so Florida would not have been any
different based on third parties if you
look at Colorado Hillary Clinton won by
two point one percent Gary Johnson had
four point nine percent of the vote you
could make the case that Hillary won
Colorado because of Gary Johnson rather
than in spite of Nevada Hillary Clinton
won Nevada by two point four percent
Gary Johnson had three point three
percent in that election Hillary Clinton
may have won Nevada because of Gary
Johnson and then if we look at New
Mexico where Hillary Clinton won by
eight point three percent lo and behold
Gary Johnson had nine point three
percent support estimate suggests ninety
percent of that would have come from
Trump or from non voters and if Hillary
Clinton uh Hillary Clinton also did end
up winning Minnesota by one point four
percent
Gary Johnson had three point nine there
so we should be thanking Gary Johnson
that this wasn't even more of a blowout
so who do we blame here we blame the DNC
and we blame Hillary Clinton primarily
and we also blame voters who were
opposed to Trump who saw this as an
election rather than as an emergency
Hillary Clinton was the wrong candidate
when over a year ago I said Bernie
Sanders is the progressive candidate I'm
voting for Bernie Sanders that was the
case now that's over we can assess this
for what it was the Benghazi scandal was
no scandal and it didn't play big league
in the race the email scandal should not
have been a scandal but it played hugely
and guys we can blame James Comey for
announcement one and letter to and all
of this different stuff we can blame
Julian Assange we can blame Russian
hackers or whatever we want but there
has to be liability you created a
liability you asked for this when the
DNC ahead of time says we are for
Hillary we know about these liabilities
and to blame racist racist or a problem
you can't change racists very easily who
vote for Donald Trump
the DNC created this mess and that's who
gets the blame number one in my book
right I mean Hillary Clinton was a poor
candidate we knew it all along this
isn't hindsight we were saying it
beforehand and really the hubris of the
DNC is blowing up in their faces now and
Rachel you know when when this happened
progressives and moderate
said Trump is bad I might not like
Hillary but we should vote for her I'd
rather Bernie or someone else we should
vote for her this should have been
treated as an emergency this was not a
normal election Obama vs. Romney it was
important to vote for President Obama
Romney was not the right path forward
but it was a real election with
relatively normal candidates this was an
emergency
and too many voters did not see it as
that yeah because he capitalized on the
anti-establishment narrative so I assume
what you're saying is that Bernie could
have kind of also capitalized on that
narrative but I don't know if he would
have been two polarizing because Trump
still really he kind of captured all of
the non educated white males by about 39
points and that gave him a mo that he
needed but what it really comes down to
is looking at as I said it would come
down to a few states and it did if you
look at Florida where Donald Trump won
by 1.3 percent and you can pick them
that back up if you want paddle 1.3
percent win if you look at Pennsylvania
a 1.2 percent when you look at Ohio
where Trump won big and then you look at
Wisconsin were Trump won by one
percentage point if you flip Wisconsin
Pennsylvania in Florida if the Comey
stuff hurt Hillary only to the degree of
2% or 1.5 percent then that lost it for
Hillary Clinton and again that's not
blaming Comey although what he did was
insane but it's saying that a candidate
with this degree of liability forget
about the fact that Hillary Clinton is
center left center center right the
liability that was implicit in Hillary
Clinton is really really disturbing and
a week there's a great article by Thomas
Frank where he said uh basically Trump
is going to the White House and liberals
put him there Hillary was the wrong
candidate Bernie Sanders was the
progressive version of Trump right this
this anti-establishment idea the DNC now
is embarrassed I hope that they are
actually it can't be the DNC that is the
gatekeeper to who is the Democratic
candidate because we end up with
candidates with major liabilities and I
hope that people are learning from this
election Pat I'm sure that Hillary
Clinton lost this election in the rest
the Rust Belt right yeah states like
Wisconsin Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania
I don't think Bernie Sanders would have
lost those states I think you would have
rallied union support energize the base
and he would have smoked Trump in this
election I don't know if I'd necessarily
agree with that because I a lot of those
people in in the Rust Belt kind of took
on the brexit type of mentality when
they're this working-class uh it manner
and I I don't necessarily know if he
would have gained as much traction there
but here's the thing that that I think
maybe you're not completely right Rachel
but Bernie Sanders was like Trump a sort
of anger candidate a different type of
anger and a lot of if we if we want to
take brexit as the example as a sort of
analogy a lot of what brexit included
within it was anger Bernie Sanders did
need to convert the lunatic crazy Trump
voters that we've seen turn into
caricatures in those interviews wait
waiting for a Trump rally
Bernie Sanders would not have gotten
them but we're talking about a very
small percentage that would have had to
flip to get states like Wisconsin and
Michigan and Pennsylvania Ohio wasn't
close but that doesn't really matter so
I think that you don't need to argue
that it would have been overwhelmingly
different with a different candidate
like Bernie because they don't it was so
close it only needed to be a little bit
different and I would also say - I mean
it Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump are
quite similar when it comes to trade
policy both were against NAFTA and they
were very similar also when it came to
their policies with their point of view
on Middle East dictators and how the US
should or shouldn't be involved with
that so now let's talk now that we
figured out who is to blame and please
the Jill Stein Gary Johnson stuff I
don't like them any more than you do but
they're not responsible for what
happened